all right awesome finally we have a
movie that takes Pixar back to its glory
days turns out the movie came out almost
10 years ago but still you know glory
days and that's good Finding Nemo in 3d
it's when I heard they were releasing
Finding Nemo in 3d I was hyped for a
couple reasons one I figured the 3d
would look really good you know it's
underwater there's a lot of depth and it
does look really good too because like I
said I wanted to see a movie that showed
us you know what Pixar used to be you
know its glory days when it made
everything great and three and two my
everlasting shame you guys now know this
I had never seen Finding Nemo until just
a couple hours ago yes I'm one of the
three people on the face of the planet
who had never seen Finding Nemo so I get
to review this movie with objective eyes
not something from my childhood or past
or anything like that and objectively as
a movie Finding Nemo it's awesome I mean
everything worked in this movie from the
very beginning the beginning is all good
then it gets kind of dark I was
surprised I was like oh okay well
alright they're going here but I knew if
the movie would go there in the
beginning we were in for a really good
movie so the story of Finding Nemo is
about Marlin and his son Nemo Marlins
are really overprotective father you
know what those father's just like you
and you know don't don't go outside the
house unless I say so
oh you can't spend the night at your
friend's place come on in because I
think yeah I don't know a bumbles gonna
eat you or something but then a deep-sea
diver captures Nemo and now Marlin has a
step out of his comfort zone and go find
his son his comfort zone is not braving
the ocean and the creatures in it at all
so that was really cool to see you know
Nemo gets separated from his dad so his
dad has to grow and Nemo has to grow in
a dark way it's a good thing for them
doesn't change the fact that you really
feel the separation anxiety it's kind of
like an American tale with fish for the
21st century then Marlin runs across
dory voiced by Ellen DeGeneres who's
really funny in the movie she's a fish
who has short-term memory loss she's
pretty much Guy Pearce from memento you
know only she's gonna help him find his
son was an odd combo but anytime there's
an odd combo in a movie like this I'm
like this is either gonna really work or
really not it worked and it was funny it
was good other than the entire premise
of the movie being really good
really relatable and really interesting
all of the side characters were really
good also all of them you know the
turtles were awesome I was like all
right it's official Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles has changed the way people view
turtles turtles get a voice they're
probably gonna be like yeah kill a bum
you did which is not a bad thing at all
that's the way it should be that's the
way I view turtles the Sharks were funny
even the fish that Nemo's hanging out
with they're awesome gill was great
voiced by Willem Dafoe this movie has a
lot of voices where you're like dude I
know that voice another one oh I know
that voice dude is that Geoffrey Rush I
knew I knew that boys it's a classic
adventure in which someone has to go out
of their comfort zone to go find someone
they love the one he loves being a son
if a movie can nail that premise it's
absolute gold and Finding Nemo is gold
why I didn't see it before today I have
no idea why I was probably working a
miserable job at the time it flew under
my radar and I never caught up on if you
haven't seen Finding Nemo I'm telling
you go watch Finding Nemo you're gonna
be like oh yeah it's great that's what
happens when Pixar doesn't make cars -
or brave it was the Golden Age of Pixar
movies you know when Pixar had that
Disney Magic to it but had the CGI tech
of Pixar you know it was a really good
combo this is one of those movies I
could go to my dad or you could probably
go to your dad and be like watch Finding
Nemo you will probably cry I can say
that to my dad knowing I'm probably
right about it because I almost cried in
Finding Nemo it's just good it's
everything I look for in an animation
and that is a movie that can appeal to
kids and adults alike in short Finding
Nemo
is awesome tacular
this year needed a little bit of help
for the animations don't worry Finding
Nemo is here to help and a little short
film at the beginning of Finding Nemo
the partysaurus Rex won or did that was
great too in fact a little toy story 3
partysaurus Rex short is also awesome
tacular it's a short one so you kiss a
short rating but it's still great when I
have to vicariously live my party days
through toys that's probably sad but it
was funny alright so your favorite
animation of all time I think I asked
you that in the Lion King mine is the
Lion King but still Finding Nemo has
inspired me to ask you that yet again
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more